who are the key figures
maybe let's put nobel prize aside for
the key figures
i like the second version of the
question because i think to try to give
a prize to one person in string there
doesn't do
justice to the diversity of the subject
that to me is so there was quite a lot
of incredible people
there in the history of quite a lot of
people i mean starting with venezuela
who wasn't talking about strings
yes i mean he wrote down the the
beginning of a string so we cannot
ignore that for sure and so
so you start with that and you go on
with various other figures and so on so
there are different epochs in string
theory
yes and different people have been
pushing it then so for example the early
epoch we just told you people like
uh like veneziano and nambu and the
saskan and others were pushing it green
and shorts or pushing it and so forth
so this was or shark and so on so these
were the initial periods of
pioneers i would say of string theory
and then there were
there were the mid 80s that edward
whitten was the major proponent of
string theory and he really
changed the landscape of string theory
in terms of what people do and how
how we view it and i think his efforts
brought a lot of attention
to the community about a heinous
community to focus on this effort as the
correct theory of
unification of forces so he brought a
lot of research as well as of course the
first-rate
work he himself did to this area so
that's in mid-80s and onwards and also
in mid-90s where he
was one of the proponents of the duality
revolution in string theory
and with that came a lot of these other
ideas that you know
led to breakthroughs involving for
example
the example i told you about black holes
and holography and the work that was
later done by maldasena about the
properties of duality between particle
physics and
quantum gravity and the connections
deeper connections of holography
and it continues and there are many
people within this range which i haven't
even mentioned
they have done fantastic important
things
how it gets recognized i think is
secondary in my opinion
than the appreciation that the effort is
collective
that in fact that to me is the more
important part of science that gets
forgotten for some reason
humanity likes heroes and science is no
exception we like heroes
but i i personally try to avoid that
trap i
i feel and in my work most of my work is
with colleagues
i have much more collaborations than
soul author papers
and i enjoy it and i think that that's
to me one of the most satisfying aspects
of science
is to interact and learn and
debate ideas with colleagues because
that influx of ideas enriches it
and that's why i i find it interesting
to me science if i was in an island and
if i was developing strength here by
myself and had nothing to do with
anybody it would be much less satisfying
in my opinion even if i could
take credit i did it yeah it won't be as
satisfying
sitting alone yeah with a big metal
drinking champagne
no i think i think to me the collective
work is more exciting and
you mentioned my getting the
breakthrough when i was getting it i
made sure to mention that it is because
of the joint work that i've done
with colleagues at that time it was
around 180 or so
collaborators and i acknowledge them in
the in the web page for them i write
all of their names and the
collaborations that led to this so to me
science is fun when it's collaboration
and yes there are
more important and less important
figures as in any field
and that's true that's true in
strengthening as well but i think that
i would like to view this as a
collective effort
you